let's go - uh-oh let's go - dontel in
Florida dontel in Florida what's going
on dontel hey David um first on a city
that you've been doing I like I
appreciate that you can do what you can
to like provided no one to take to all
the protesters what's going on right now
thank you
and so I have two topics about these
protesters I want to talk about the
first is the darling display of
gratuitous violence and lawlessness
police officers in police departments
across the country mm-hmm ironic we have
people are protesting police brutality
right and in fact is even worse than
that dontel dontel please do me the
favor of keeping the phone just a little
further from your mouth that the
mouthpiece because you're you're coming
in hot and we can't control it on our
end - well right now it's not it's
actually there's an even crazier
hypocrisy which is all of this is was
catalyzed by police brutality and the
president came out and said I think the
governor's need to be more brutal in
their responses which could not be more
backwards so yes agree with you spot-on
with a with the first part go ahead and
so these are people who are their job
they are trying to maintain the peace
yes and what we're seeing is they're
doing the exact opposite they're the
ones who are initiating the violence the
overwhelming majority of time at these
peaceful protests so and a lot of times
when we see these videos normally when
we see videos of police brutality a lot
of people in this country on the left
and on the right they say that those are
just the bad apples the overwhelming
majority of the police they're good
they're law-abiding and all of that yeah
but all of that what up and smoke over
the last few days was entire Police
Department's at police precincts
mobilized to violently break up lawful
protest and the good police officers the
law-abiding police officers they didn't
intervene and they didn't do anything
while the other police officers were
assaulting protesters which is illegal
and it could be a
before by the way yeah think about yeah
yeah so what do you think about the idea
of the police officers who've been on
video assaulting protesters and
unlawfully breaking a constitutional
protecting protest what do you think
about them being arrested and prosecuted
yeah so I hope that they are I mean I
hope every Internal Affairs and this I'm
gonna have a segment actually coming up
later on the show today where I'm going
to talk about exactly how police
training should be totally restructured
but we I hope that these videos that are
spreading like wildfire are actually
turned over and looked at by police
internal investigation departments my
understanding is that there have been
some officers caught on tape who already
are now entering the discipline process
you know we'll have to follow to see if
anything actually comes of it but I'm
completely with you and in fact I
tweeted a couple of days ago are we
building a list of names are we
identifying the people that are so
brutally going you know going after even
press like people who are just they're
reporting on what's going on they should
all week but we've got to be taking
names and and going after all of the
ones that have broken the law and so the
top one is talked about is moving so yes
there are people who are opportunistic
and they aren't really involved in the
Georgia Florida protests right and they
see this as an opportunity needs to take
advantage of the situation yes that's
true
yep but if there are also people who are
involved in the protest who are engaged
in looting - so the what for me it all
comes back to the question of would
people be rioting will people be looting
if they were financially financially
secure because people are forgetting we
are in the middle of a economic
depression forty million people have
lost their jobs
forty percent of small businesses might
be permanently closed in the next couple
months right thousands of landlords
right now are in court filing eviction
for eviction so that as soon as these
temporary bans are listed in the next
couple of days they can start
Tom people are on the street so and this
is and the response from our government
Democrats and Republicans has been to
ignore the the economic depression and
we people hire and drive while they bail
out corporations in the richest people
in the country to the tune of the
trillions of dollars and before all this
even happen we were already dealing with
historic wealth inequality in this
country and the living economic
condition for a lot of people with
desperate so when you add this on top of
course you're gonna get looting so my
suggestion to people if you want to stop
the looting if you want to limit the
ruining if not to shoot the people who
are they doing it it's not you shouldn't
you're not gonna do it by calling them
out if you want them to stop moving the
way I see the best way to do it is to
have them organized and and do targeted
protest at the politicians that Congress
I think I get the point John tell you're
coming you're coming in so distorted
that I'm gonna have to let you go but I
basically agree with you however I
wouldn't absolve any individual looter
of the fact that they are breaking the
law but you're completely right that we
can't ignore the circumstances that lead
to people feeling like they need to loot
there's no question about it I'm with
you Don tell on that okay I'm gonna let
you go and we are we thought our phone
system was working perfectly and then
Don tell was just coming in so hot gonna
have to keep looking into that